Speaker 1: All right. One more quick Trump
story. We've really relegated the Trump stuff
to like the back pages of the show lately. Donald
Trump again has posted captured to essential.
Captured is a Twitter account right leaning.
I don't know who runs it. It's all nonsense.
Trump posting a captured poll. The poll asked who
will get second place in the Republican primary?
Ron DeSantis or Vivek Ramaswamy. In this poll,
Vivek Ramaswamy will, according to the voters,
two thirds of those who voted on this say that
Vivek Ramaswamy will end up in second place in
the Republican primary, and only about one
third say that Ron DeSantis will end up in
second place in the Republican primary. This
is all meant to attack Ron DeSantis. Now,
if you look at actual polling, the numbers are
very different. According to polling, Vivek
Ramaswamy is polling 2.4%, whereas Ron DeSantis
has like eight times that level of support at 21%.
So if we look at anything that is evidence based,
anything empirical, it doesn't appear as though
Vivek Ramaswamy is going to surge and surpass Ron
DeSantis. But we know that the real numbers never
really mattered to these people. Interestingly,
I do want to just point out a little bit. There's
not been any major polling shift for several
weeks, which is why I've not been talking about
polling. But in looking at these numbers, what
you might see is that dating back to June 20th,
there's been a little bit of an uptick again for
Donald Trump and a little bit of a downswing for
Ron DeSantis, although, again, big picture, if you
zoom out and you go back to Trump's first arrest,
Trump has been very steady in the low fifties and
Ron DeSantis has been very steady right around 21.
Nobody else really making any move other than
Mike Pence, who has seen a surge from roughly 4
to 6. It's an explosive six. Trust me, But it is
still only six. What is the what is responsible
for that? Quite frankly, I have no idea. Six
is still not going to get you particularly far.